thanks for joining us America trevor is
with us in Utah happy new year Trevor
happy New Year to you as well how are
you
better than I deserve how can I help sir
thank you my wife and I just recently
started Financial Peace University and
had baby steps one last month and are
currently working on baby steps - great
our questions about the credit card debt
and what we should do $19,000 in credit
card debt
10,000 and medical and 32 in our cars
unfortunately and with minimum payments
were just kind of falling behind so we
had to protect our four walls and start
on that and start making minimum
payments and with that through my car
payment which is a long time and up to
date my credit card is with the same
bank and so they're saying that it's
collateral against the car and they can
repossess it so they're kind of work on
that too
and so I'm just kind of trying to figure
out options on where to go from here
what's your household income we take of
home about five thousand a month you
need to sell some cars don't you yeah we
do unfortunately we're upside down and
um because in my life I have both rolled
over previous cars into these guitars
mm-hmm okay so which one is the most
expensive they're both about 16,000
right now that we owe on them or the one
I'd take home first is this bank that's
misbehaving and I'm gonna get those
people out of my life you don't have any
checking with them do you know we don't
good
who's the bank it's America first the
local credit union hearing you talk yeah
okay well I would get everything out of
them as fast as I can since they're
being buts
the other thing I do sit down with them
in person and go you know what you've
got this credit card debt that's
unsecured you've got a portion of this
car that's unsecured why don't we put
that on an unsecured personal loan let
me sell the car and let's get rid of it
let's get rid of some of the debt sit
down with them in person in the
manager's office okay not by email and
not over the phone because they have an
unsecured loan what's the
sixteen thousand dollar car probably
worth right what's it worth it's I I had
a little book that's probably around
12,000 maybe that's better
all right so they've got a four thousand
dollar unsecured loan and a twelve
thousand dollar car loan plus a credit
card debt how much is a credit card debt
it's about twenty five hundred any time
so they need to make you a $6,500
personal loan and let you sell the car
and that'll get rid of one car and it'll
get it off of credit cards right you'll
just have a little personal unsecured
loan with them which is what they've got
now they don't have security now on the
only security they've got now is $12,000
car right right and they got six
thousand five hundred approximately in
unsecured debt right now all we're doing
is admitting that so if they balk at all
just try to remind them of that and rub
their nose and go that's unsecured loan
anyway Bubba and let's start clearing
that off because you kid the problem is
these car payments are killing you guys
and you can't even make your payments
right so you've got to get offload some
of the debt just to get in balance again
so you can begin to make progress
instead of systematically going behind
every month right you're making the
right choice to do the four walls first
but that's a temporary thing that's not
a long-term strategy that's I'm gonna
survive this month and do the right
things like eat and keep my lights on
before I worry about a stupid credit
card but you know then immediately you
go I'm gonna sit down this Bank I'm
gonna get this car sold who's the other
car loan with its do another credit
union here and Utah University we do the
same thing with them then let's get us a
couple of one get us a couple of one
thousand dollar cars and drive them did
we get this mess straightened down and
then the other thing is you stopped
anything coming out of your check you
know stop your 401ks stop anything like
that let's try to get as much money home
as possible to pay these bills and of
course start looking for extra work
anything you can do you know delivering
pizzas driving uber whatever and you
know
that makes a lot of sense you get
another thousand dollars a month coming
in and you adjust some of these other
things you can clear this debt pretty
quickly but we've got to get back on top
of it here and it's going to require
some steps in those directions but I'd
say both those cars need to go because
I'm guessing they're probably high
interest rates too it sounds like it
sounds like they're bad deals all the
way around you got stung you had car
fever so I hope that helps man thanks
for calling in if you can if I can help
you more you let me know I think you can
do this but you're going to make some
pretty dramatic steps because you're in
a pretty dramatic situation